Sylvain merci vous êtes militaire vous
habitez au quartier Bellevue vous êtes
très bien dans ce quartier ça se passe
très bien pour vous
ça se passe très bien sauf les rodéo
malheureusement c'est le seul point
c'est le seul hic qui a dans le quartier
il y en a énormément
ça va de trois fois par semaine minimum
et quand c'est en vacances bien sûr
c'est tous les jours et puis pour eux
c'est un jeu et justement et donc les
les donc les riverains sont au bout de
leur vie c'est ça les habitants de il y
en a qui sont qui avaient des enfants
parce que j'ai vu des reportages aussi
obligé de déménager le week-end
du site rodéo parce que l'enfant dormait
pas en bas âge et tout
si on a pareil il y en a plein qui ont
du déménager à côté à cause de ça
justement
alors
n'est pas de souci particulier avec le
voisinage
particulier juste les les
urbains parce que c'est pareil alors
pendant les vacances il paraît que c'est
toute la journée
c'est de le matin heureusement énorme
mais ça commence 14h et ça finit jusqu'à
22h des fois alors la question toi tout
le monde doit se poser Benaim mais la
police
j'ai envie de dire mais c'est je les
appelle je les appelle et je pense pas
être le seul à les appeler au moins
toutes les 10 minutes pour pour que ça
bouge et tout ce qui nous dit c'est on
envoie des patrouilles ils sont ils ont
pas assez d'effectif donc je vais venir
le croire mais bon ça fait depuis 2017
que Bellevue est un quartier qui craint
le maire est au courant que c'est un
quartier qui craint mais n'a pas envie
de mettre des caméras de surveillance
dans ce quartier
de il y a aucun ralentisseur rien donc
les jeunes ils voient une liste une
piste droite et puis
on Avant Guingamp quoi
c'est très rapide il faut le faire assez
vite les gens dorment de partout
on marche sur la tête dans ce pays c'est
on parle dans un instant avec ces Gwen
mais je vous dis on s'est en marche sur
la tête ici enfin tout marche à l'envers
c'est un truc de fou euh donc ça dure
combien de temps cette affaire fait
combien de temps là c'est depuis
facilement janvier et c'est toutes les
semaines toutes les semaines mais juste
mettre des ralentisseurs
ils ont carrément fait un rodéo mais
dans un centre commercial côté
d'Échirolles
et ils sont rentrés dans le centre
commercial et ils ont fait un rodéo dans
le centre commercial c'est assez dingue
alors donc rien ne bouge
alors donc comme vous l'avez dit tout
est dans stand-by ça continue là
toujours
le lendemain après mon mon comment dire
mon intervention
parce que ils ont commencé juste le
lendemain d'accord je recommencer alors
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
il y avait un rodé urbain vous décidez
d'intervenir d'intervenir vous dites
quoi il paraît que vous leur parlez
gentiment au départ c'est ça je leur
demande juste d'arrêter
et en fait si le problème qui se passe
c'est que j'ai mon appartement qui donne
sur un terrain de jeu juste à la sortie
de chez moi il y a des jeunes qui qui
jouent juste à côté et ils passent eux
ils les rasent ils en ont rien à faire
et c'est vraiment un danger c'est un
chemin normalement que pour les piétons
et motos n'ont pas le droit de passer là
et eux ils vont plein pot ils y vont
sans casque sans rien
les motos le bruit ben c'est un enfer
ils ont quel âge c'est les adolescents
dans la tranche d'âge 14-17 ans
au niveau de Bellevue donc à Brest
exactement c'est un quartier qui est
réputé déjà pour craindre
c'est un quartier très j'ai très chaud
d'accord
j'ai malheureusement acheté nos
propriétés donc
sans réfléchir avant je voulais vraiment
partir de tout ce qui est mon de
militaire et base militaire pour avoir
mon indépendance
ce que ce que j'aurais pu réfléchir
avant
et malheureusement
les rodéo c'est interviennent assez
récurrent
et cela le dimanche c'était le pour moi
c'était la goutte de trône donc je suis
j'ai voulu intervenir et je suis sorti
dire aux jeunes de stopper ces rodéo
il a pas été d'accord avec ça il a dit
il y a pas de souci je reviens il est
revenu avec une vingtaine de ces jeunes
je
du coup ils sont revenus et de gueuler
je suis sorti de chez moi et c'est là
que ils se sont jetés sur moi avec la
batte de baseball des brans une branche
d'arbre des cailloux et c'était comment
était une vingtaine une bonne vingtaine
de jeunes vous étiez tout seul moi
j'étais tout seul il y avait il y avait
une dame avec ses enfants sur le terrain
de jeu mais bon bien sûr ce qui est
logique intervenir
et tout et donc on peut face à un jeune
donc on peut rien faire quoi qu'est-ce
qui vous ont dit
s'ils ont ils ont rien dit ils ont juste
tabasser et puis c'est c'est la violence
gratuite ils connaissent que ça
malheureusement c'est si triste à dire
mais
c'est il y a un manque d'éducation de
leur côté et puis c'est
on dit que vous avez été poignardé pour
une heure au niveau de Facebook du coup
d'accord et après
j'avais au niveau du crâne aussi des
points de suture et bien sûr après le
coca et
ça a duré combien de temps
une minute ou deux après
peut-être que je grossis les choses mais
là vous avez porté plainte bien entendu
j'ai porté plainte hier du coup le
lendemain de l'agression
ça en est où
là je dois retourner jeudi pour
identifier les jeunes ils ont déjà été
on a déjà une idée de
qui ont été appréhendés
il y a quelques témoins qui ont aidé à
identifier des jeunes donc ils vont voir
si ça coordonne si j'arrive à me
rappeler de
la tête de certains jeunes parce que
c'est vrai qu'il y en a beaucoup et je
peux plus tout regarder tous les visages
il y a pas du tout de caméra de
surveillance il y a ce que le maire
justement ne veut pas en mettre dans les
dans les cartes et qui craint comme ça
mais je crois que les jeunes sont connus
quand même dans le quartier non les
jeunes sont connus et que comme je vous
l'ai dit en fait ils savent très bien où
sont les motos ils savent
doivent se douter ou sont les jeunes
aussi
c'est des HLM des logements sociaux donc
les
comment dire il y a un gardien qui
s'occupe de chaque logement qui a dit
carrément aux policiers voilà mais les
motos sont en tels immeubles et tout
donc les policiers sont au courant ils
savent
et quand j'avais appelé les policiers
ils m'ont dit on se met on sait où ils
sont mais on peut pas intervenir parce
que il y a des procédures parce qu'il y
a si parce que il y a ça il y a toujours
des des toujours des bars
alors aujourd'hui quels sont les
séquelles que vous allez ça aurait pu
être beaucoup plus grave
là les séquelles donc c'est plus j'ai
envie de dire c'est plus de peur que que
de mal aujourd'hui vous avez peur de
sortir chez vous j'ai peur un peu peur
des représailles parce que c'est vrai
que
c'est des jeunes et tout ce qu'ils vont
chercher c'est tabassé et comme j'ai dit
dans les autres portages c'est pas des
jeunes qui vont chercher à tuer
quelqu'un parce que
le vouloir te tuer une personne c'est
quelque chose de fort et même les
militaires et l'armée de terre ou même
les Lyonnais c'est on est formé pour ça
et même formé il y en a et qui
je suis désolé exprès de l'expression
mais il se chie dessus
c'est quelque chose qui est très dur et
pour les jeunes comme ça ils ont pas ils
ont pas envie de tuer tout ce qu'ils ont
envie c'est de dire voilà c'est mon
quartier voilà puis
tu fais pas la loi c'est moi qui l'a
fait aujourd'hui ça va être quoi la
suite pour vous
la suite malheureusement c'est de soit
louer l'appart ou soit le revendre elle
est partie c'est encore une fois c'est
encore une fois les agresser et harceler
qui partent c'est toujours les
agressions il reste mais c'est c'est ça
et puis c'est toujours pareil que ça
soit les appartements ou même dans les
dans les écoles les agresser les
victimes c'est toujours eux qui
exactement
et heureusement que j'ai la j'ai demandé
pour retourner sur le sur base qui est
beaucoup plus sécurisé du coup et c'est
incroyable
dans les jours à venir vu la violence de
ce qui s'est passé il faut le dire très
clairement vous auriez pu mourir c'était
un desserlement de haine et de violence
et ce qui est incompréhensible alors que
Gérald Darmanin le ministre de
l'Intérieur a érigé la lutte contre les
rodéo en priorité il y a eu 6900
opérations à Brest rien donc ça veut
dire que c'est c'est même pas c'est à
dire que le ministre de la de
l'Intérieur veut que ça bouge et à Brest
on a l'impression que rien ne bouge
parce que qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est
quoi
[Musique]
à chaque fois c'est que c'est ça le
maire c'est pas son boulot le maire
socialiste et il est élu depuis 2001
donc réélu régulièrement quand même
maintenant là je pense que il y a
vraiment faille dans ce quartier comme
le dit les policiers aussi peut-être il
y a aussi un manque d'effectif mais bon
depuis 2017 un manque d'effectif un
moment un moment là c'est pas un moment
ça doit être une priorité il se passe
quoi d'autre à Brest non mais
excusez-moi c'est parce quoi d'autre ah
non mais pas grand chose ça doit être
non mais ça doit être la priorité c'est
un quartier qui est connu comme tel
c'est incroyable que la police ne
réagisse pas alors le problème c'est que
pour les
urbains effectivement à partir du moment
où ils sont prévenus souvent les jeunes
ont le temps de partir mais il faut
qu'il y ait des policiers en patrouille
qui soit positionnés là où vous habitez
pour les stopper s'ils viennent tous les
jours sinon c'est pas possible c'est pas
des policiers qu'il faut c'est des rodéo
urbains ça existe depuis 15 20 moi j'ai
connu ça aussi depuis 25 ans c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui les ben tu peux mettre
autant de policiers
[Musique]
je pense que il y a c'est ça en fait ils
ont ils ont peur des représailles les
filles qui pendant les policiers parce
que Flix c'est un peu lire et c'est
ça en fait c'est c'est la peur aussi
bien de dans les voisins pour pas
vouloir témoigner que dans la police
pour pas vouloir vraiment intervenir et
faire leur boulot
[Musique]